this I think there's so much the worst
thing I've ever done for BuzzFeed easily
all I know about threading is it looks
like floss I know that there's some
string string needles I don't know what
goes on needles didn't know oh thank god
there's no needles I know nothing about
threading hopefully I won't even notice
it is that stupid
[Music]
hi my name is Aruna I am Dasia you want
more manly right well I want something
look even funny they will grow back
there a their seat belt oh yeah that is
nice that feels and that is just like
normal like sewing thread yes as a
normal no mhm
we're gonna take your hair you're gonna
remove your hair with the fry
oh my god I will say that there are many
other things I'd rather be doing than
this
like I don't being punched in the
stomach the middle like where the area
she's doing now is actually not being
flat off oh wow
are you suppose are you wiping blood off
I didn't even volunteer for this video
Gabby volunteered me for this video nope
don't wear makeup Nixon oh I'm sure it's
fine Aruna yeah I look a little less
Greek that's clean oh [ __ ] it felt like
all my eyebrows would be gone that's
quick and easy the girls they're used to
waxing and everything there's so much
tougher than me yeah I would bring a
police officer firemen next time if I
were to be this again I'm such a baby
I don't think I can ever get this
precisely
I did it I'm happy that I have on fleek
eyebrows yes was it worth the journey
I'm not sure we'll see
[Music]